♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden appeared
last night on "60 Minutes"
and spoke about the ongoing war
between Israel and Hamas.
And you could tell
he was nervous
because he kept asking,
"How many more minutes?"
The Senate returned this week
from a fall recess.
Unfortunately, the House
is still in detention.
House Republicans on Friday
picked Ohio Congressman
Jim Jordan
to be their nominee
for Speaker of the House.
The vote was 81 "no"
and 124, "Yeah, fine."
Republican Congressman
George Santos
reportedly got into
a screaming match on Thursday
with an activist
at the Capitol
while holding
a two-month-old baby.
So finally,
he's actually representing
the people
of Long Island.
Currently indicted Republican
Congressman George Santos
was seen leaving
a colleague's office
carrying a mysterious baby,
and when he was asked
if the baby was his,
he replied, "Not yet."
Which brings us to a segment
called, "OK, But For Real,
Someone's Got Eyes
On This Baby, Right?"
♪♪
Look, I know there's a lot going
on in the House right now,
what with the no speaker
and the nomination
of election-denying
insurrectionists.
But for real, someone's got eyes
on this baby, right?
Because I don't know
what's happening in this photo,
I just know it's not good.
George Santos is currently
under indictment for 23 crimes,
and by the look of this picture,
he's going for 24.
I mean, the man's running like
he just intercepted a football.
And then when asked
if the baby was his,
Santos opted for the most
dramatic possible answer --
"Not yet."
Is he a congressman or
a "Days of Our Lives" villain?
What does "not yet" mean?
Is he going to adopt it,
or is he going to do away
with the parents?
Someone please send me a picture
of this baby
holding today's paper,
because right now
I'm very concerned.
But at least now we know
George Santos
isn't the craziest person
on Capitol Hill.
That title goes to whoever
voluntarily handed a baby
to George Santos.
-This has been...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The CEO of the movie theater
chain AMC posted to X last week
that a blackmailer
had catfished him
and attempted
to extort him for money.
"I know the feeling,"
said someone who just paid $40
for popcorn and a drink.
A woman in Australia
is recovering
after she tried to rescue
a platypus with her bare hands,
and was stabbed
with its poisonous spurs.
Though in her defense,
even the platypus
didn't know it could do that.
"Damn, I truly am weird as hell.
"Every day, I learn
a new crazy fact about me.
Oh, I just laid an egg."
And finally, Netflix recently
unveiled plans to open two
so-called Netflix House venues
where customers can eat, drink,
and buy merchandise,
or more likely,
just look at the menu
for two hours and leave.
♪♪
During the first ballot in
today's House speakership vote,
Ohio congressman Jim Jordan
fell short of the 217 votes
necessary to become speaker.
But Republicans are determined
to keep trying
until they finally get it wrong.
[ Laughter ]
During the first ballot in
today's House speakership vote,
several Republicans voted
for former New York
congressman Lee Zeldin,
which means they are
running out of options,
even alphabetically.
"What about Ziggy Zyzax?
He's -- He's strong
on the border, right?"
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
over the weekend
announced that about
200 Floridians
were evacuated from Israel
and landed in Tampa,
marking the first time
in recorded history
that anyone was happy
to land in Tampa.
[ Laughter ]
"Well, maybe we'll
meet Tom Brady.
"What? Retired?"
In a post today on Truth Social,
former president Trump said
that Ohio congressman Jim Jordan
will be a great House speaker
and added that he had
his "complete and total
endorsement."
"Good luck with that,"
said David Perdue, Kari Lake,
Doug Mastriano,
Herschel Walker, Dr. Oz,
and that kid he forced
to mow his lawn.
[ Laughter, applause ]
It's a long list.
Justice Amy Coney Barrett
said in an interview yesterday
that the Supreme Court
should adopt an ethics code
and added, "All nine justices
are very committed
to the highest standards
of ethical conduct."
And when he read that interview,
Clarence Thomas laughed so hard,
he almost fell off
a billionaire's yacht.
[ Laughter ]
The drug manufacturer
Novo Nordisk announced yesterday
that it has acquired
a new hypertension drug
for $1.3 billion,
but they quickly
made that money back
after selling
five vials of insulin.
[ Audience groans ]
I guess my question is, where
did we think the laugh was?
[ Laughter ]
Like, as I'm saying it,
I'm like,
"Wait, this might not work."
[ Laughter ]
Alright, well...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Got something pretty cool,
though,
'cause you had to
suffer through that.
Everybody look under your seat.
Vial of insulin.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
baby boomers said
their top source for new slang
is younger family members.
Said your grandma,
"I crashed my whip
into the post office again."
[ Laughter ]
According to the same survey,
the most popular new slang word
used in Florida is "sus."
Well, yeah.
Have you ever been there?
I'm surprised it's not also
the most popular baby name.
"Yeah, we're calling him Sus.
We don't --
Doesn't look like either of us."
[ Laughter ]
Walmart has announced it will
offer the limited-edition
Van Leeuwen Kraft
Macaroni & Cheese ice cream.
It's a great way to make sure
your death is ruled a suicide.
[ Laughter ]
And finally --
You know would be good
with that?
Little vial of something.
Not going to say what.
And finally, Coca-Cola
and the makers of Absolut Vodka
announced yesterday
they're planning to release
a new ready-to-drink
vodka-Sprite cocktail,
because if you're mixing
vodka and Sprite,
you're ready to drink.
Yeah, I don't know, just two
liquids, one of them alcohol.
♪♪
Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan
failed to secure
enough votes today
in the second round of voting
to become House Speaker,
and received only 199 votes.
That's worse
than he did yesterday.
If they keep doing votes,
he's eventually
gonna get to zero,
and then he'll fade away like
Marty McFly in a family photo.
[ Laughter ]
The White House announced
last night
that President Biden's
scheduled stop in Jordan
has been canceled,
making it the second Jordan
to get shut down this week.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden arrived
this morning in Israel,
making him the first president
to visit Israel
during a time of war,
which is pretty dangerous.
But he should be okay once
he makes it down the stairs.
[ Laughter ]
The Treasury Department
announced new sanctions today
against 10 entities
that are linked to Hamas,
including the cryptocurrency
firm Buy Cash.
Oh, uh, was a cryptocurrency
firm up to no good?
[ Laughter ]
And it's called Buy Cash?
"Hey, what's a good
non-suspicious name
"for a crypto firm?
How about Buy Cash?"
[ Laughter ]
If I drove past a strip mall
and there was a store
called Buy Cash,
I would lock my doors
and call the police.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Congresswoman
Anna Paulina Luna
reportedly brought
her newborn baby
to yesterday's
House Speaker vote.
Well, congratulations
to the new mom
and the new Speaker!
[ Laughter ]
Baby with a gavel!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Baby with a gavel.
That's one of comedy's
first rules.
Can't go wrong with a baby
with a gavel.
Former President Trump yesterday
attacked the judge
overseeing
his civil fraud trial,
in a post on Truth Social,
and said he's serving "as judge,
jury, and everything else."
I'm guessing this was after
three failed attempts
to spell "executioner."
[ Laughter ]
[As Trump] Judge, jury,
and big guy with ax and mask.
[ Laughter ]
-[Normal voice] That's right.
Trump attacked the judge
overseeing his civil fraud trial
despite being under
a partial gag order.
Yeah, I don't think you can...
Yeah, don't...
[ Gibberish ]
[Bleep]
I know, I stumbled
on the wording earlier,
and I didn't rewrite it,
and it's my fault.
Okay, here we go.
Alright. Yeah.
Let's go back and take it again.
It's definitely...
This isn't gonna
throw it at all.
[ Laughter ]
I don't -- I don't even think
they've noticed I flubbed up.
[ Laughter ]
I've played it so smoothly.
That's right.
Trump attacked the judge
overseeing his civil fraud trial
despite being under
a partial gag order.
Yeah, you don't think
you can shut Trump up
with a partial gag order,
do you?
You can't even shut him up
with a full gag order.
You could put them in the full
Hannibal Lecter outfit,
and he would still find a way
to get the word out.
[ Laughter ]
In an effort to reduce pollution
caused by microplastics,
a European Union ban on the sale
of loose plastic glitter
went into effect this week.
Some great news that, sadly,
there was no way to celebrate.
[ Laughter ]
United Airlines
has reportedly decided
to implement
a new boarding strategy
that allows economy passengers
in window seats to board first.
Meanwhile, Spirit Airlines
has decided
to streamline boarding
with a starting gun.
[ Laughter ]
The US Mint yesterday announced
that journalist Ida B. Wells
will be honored
with her face on a quarter.
Because what greater honor
than being bounced
into a Solo cup
by a drunk freshman?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Netflix recently
unveiled plans
for its first
live sports event,
which will feature
Formula One drivers and golfers
teaming up to compete
in a golf tournament.
So, if you love the intense,
high-speed excitement
of Formula One racing,
get ready to strap yourself in
for some golf.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke
from the Oval Office
tonight in a primetime address
and asked Congress to approve
$100 billion in emergency funds.
Well, good luck with that.
We can't even get Congress
to approve each other.
Republican Congressman
Carlos Giménez said yesterday
that his office
has received robocalls
encouraging to vote for Ohio
congressman Jim Jordan.
But then he remembered
he actually saved
Jordan's number
as "Scam Likely."
A group of moderate
Republican lawmakers
are reportedly pushing
to temporarily empower
acting House Speaker Pro Tem
Patrick McHenry.
Oh, you mean this guy?
The --
The congressman from Asgard?
Are we sure the lectern
can handle it?
He slammed that thing like
they just canceled "Frasier."
Come on.
That dude watches "Frasier."
While leaving court yesterday,
former President Trump
said that he "probably
won't return this week"
because of an upcoming
golf tournament
at his Miami golf club
and he doesn't want to miss it
because it's probably
the last time
it will be considered
his Miami golf club.
A man in Kenya was arrested
recently for allegedly
impersonating a lawyer
and winning dozens of lawsuits.
"I have the exact opposite
problem,"
said Rudy Giuliani.
"Maybe I should stop
pretending!"
In his upcoming biography,
Utah Senator Mitt Romney
criticizes former Texas governor
Rick Perry and says,
"Republicans must realize
that we have to have someone
who can complete a sentence."
Responded Perry, "How dare --"
The drugstore chain
Rite Aid announced yesterday
that it will close
at least 150 stores.
So, the Rite Aid
I was in last week.
You're telling me
that was open?
I should have paid somebody.
And finally, a couple recently
got married
during the 10-second pit stop
of a NASCAR race.
And this is embarrassing.
The honeymoon was even faster.
"I swear this never happens."
That was the monologue,
everybody!
♪♪